Oh God raagh form its first man son
I need angry I'm just that excited oh my
god man I'm so excited to this thing I
wish I could see me right now man
sorry man like you the ending to this
let me tell you something that eobard
thawne you but I thought if I thought my
favorite villain of all time one of the
best villains that there's ever been in
the history of like any comic book
publication ever he's got so much
character he's got so much pizazz he's
got so much of that stuff it's just like
oh man if I could be a bad guy I'd be
him that's pretty messed up but this
follows the whole idea of the butt right
like this is just the epilogue of the
button leading into you a new story
running scared but God heaven and this
is not just freaking to make Joshua
Williamson imitation right now man if
God was right in the flash right now is
what it would look like right now this
is just this isn't amazing it's just the
baby sort I was calm down let's calm
down because we spent like a minute
saying pretty much nothing let's calm
down let's relax so the cool thing about
this is that this initially picks up in
the 25th century right well at least it
does to a degree and we get to sort of
back-and-forth thing now in terms of
like jumping between like explanations
or jumping between points in time this
only really happens twice it only really
happen this time and one other time but
it's designed to mimic the nature of
eobard thawne and we'll get that here in
a second but jumping back I mean what
this really just kind of does is it
actually changes things it turns them on
its head because it goes through this
whole legacy of all the different
flashes that have ever existed for
example the Godspeed uniform is there
which basically tells us that following
the introduction of the Speed Force
storms across this across Central City
and Godspeed gaining his powers that the
future was retroactive Lee affected by
what it is a took place in the past
resulting in Godspeed and being
introduced to the whole idea of the
flash mythos but it shows us all these
different iterations Barry Allen Wally
West
you know the classic Wally West the new
52 while he was all these different
versions but the huge difference here is
that were basically told about the
character of eobard thawne and then
instead of the two of them being enemies
the two of them are actually allies or
at least that's the story is being given
to us now this is cool because remember
eobard thawne is a guy that was obsessed
with the concept of Barry Allen he was
with the idea of the flash she was never
connected to him he wasn't part of the
family line or anything like that he was
just a guy in the future who is obsessed
with the idea of the flash he basically
had surgery done to make himself look
like Barry Allen he gave himself speed
for powers he went to the Past with the
intention of meeting Barry only to
basically lose his way when he arrived
due to the effects of time travel and
then going through and looking at the
flashes you know museum coming to the
realization that he was destined to be
the Flash's most notable enemy he had a
psychotic break and the two of them
became two of the most popular foes
who've ever existed in comic books and
so what we do is we follow up with this
little bit of a intro here with the
present-day picking up with the idea of
Barry Allen now what Joshua Williamson
does here is actually pretty genius
because we know that eobard thawne so we
can't die eobard thawne is effectively
immortal for one of two reasons the
first is the reason as explained here
and the second is the nature of eobard
thawne which we'll talk about as we get
you know as we get further into this
video but with regard to this little
segment here what Barry Allen basically
says is that whoever was that
quote-unquote destroyed eobard thawne
didn't actually destroy him instead they
basically slowed him down slowed down
his connection to the you know to the
Speed Force or the negative Speed Force
in his case and and ultimately it
basically slowed down his healing factor
but his body's still recovering and
that's the cool thing about this because
remember when it comes to speedsters so
long as they're connected to the Speed
Force their body will heal and so in the
case of eobard thawne because he's so
powerful because he's the only person
that draws on a negative Speed Force
this sort of antithesis to the Speed
Force proper then what it means is that
all that energy basically flows directly
into him he doesn't really have to share
it with anybody so it's like if Barry
Allen was the only flash that existed
the Speed Force would flow entirely into
him and nobody else again this is kind
of a necessary thing because if the
Speed Force were a battery then it's
like having a battery that a phone's
charging off of and radios charging off
of and a multitude of other things the
more things you have hooked up to that
battery the faster you're going to drain
its life the Speed Force is the exact
same way and so with regards to this
whole idea of eobard thawne what it
means is that despite him having been
you know quote-unquote killed or at
least presumed to have been killed by
dr. Manhattan he was really more just
like incinerated but his body physically
survived and so because his body
physically survived he will simply just
heal now this tells
that in order for eobard thawne to be
destroyed in any one particular place in
time he'd have to totally incinerate his
body but the fact remains
eobard thawne simply cannot die and the
reason why we get into this is because
of the fact that Barry Allen of course
basically had a birthday party thrown
formed by iris West and the various
members of the you know the central city
crime labs and there I guess stylized
and so on and so forth and it's
religious kind of a celebratory thing
but the entire time this is happening
Barry's doing nothing more than just
kind of recollecting on the events of
the button you know this guy with this
weird funky helmet that there he never
you know doesn't know who he is of
course we know that's Jay Garrick and
that's the coolest thing is because when
DC launched the new 52
they basically reinvigorated earth to
this alternate reality where the Golden
Age of superheroes resided and the
reason why that matters is because in
classic DC earth Q was eliminated after
crisis on Infinite Earths and eventually
came back during Infinite Crisis Jay
Garrick was like old man flash right
like he was just this older guy who just
ran not nearly as fast as Barry Allen
but he ran pretty fast but he brought a
kind of wisdom the kind of hope to the
flash family that really wasn't
available from anybody else just because
he'd been the flash in his own universe
for so incredibly long and humanity
really kind of viewed that reality's
version of superheroes a little
different than they did in the main DC
Universe but if you were to look for
example at like an Alex Ross rendering
of Jay Garrick if you feel some kind of
surge of hope or kind of this feeling of
nostalgia or something along those lines
that's what DC was always trying to put
forward when it came to the character of
Jay Garrick whether it was in the nature
of the stories that were being told the
way that he was drawn the events as they
were unfolding whenever it is that Jay
Garrick showed up sure he wouldn't be
able to defeat eobard thawne but the
hope that he brought with him the
nostalgia the kind of reinvigoration the
hey we can pull this off that kind of
feeling I was always like the little bit
of an extra boost that like Barry or
Wally or somebody needed in order to
basically take on or take out whatever
feeling they were facing off against so
it was really kind of a cool thing
that's why we loved him his old man
flash because he's just kind of this
great you know this great bit of
invigoration here but remember during
the events of DC rebirth with the button
with new 52 Jay Garrick was kind of
rebooted but people didn't really care
for him too much his character was
alright but if they had to choose
between like the classic Jay Garrick or
the modern game your modern Jay Garrick
they would choose the classic Jay
Garrick the modern Jay Garrick wasn't
terrible not by any standard of
measurement it wasn't anything like that
it
just kind of a nostalgic thing for a lot
of older readers and so d/c rebirth was
sort of teasing the idea that jay
garrick is going to come back and the
way do we notice is because by the
statements that are made in this
particular story when we read the button
we were kind of left to believe that
maybe jay garrick was incinerated he was
being held captive somewhere he escaped
just in the nick of time where at least
was able to get out just in the nick of
time to help Barry and M Bruce Wayne
escape the timestream and then was
yanked back in again we didn't know if
he was killed we didn't really know what
it was it was going on all we knew was
that much like the classic Wally West
the only way for Jay Garrick to escape
his confinement so to speak was for
Barry Allen to remember who he was and
tether him to the main DC Universe
instead of whoever it was that he was
being held but because Barry couldn't
remember who he was Jay Garrick just
kind of went back to whatever stasis pod
or you know whoever it was was holding
on to him presumably dr. Manhattan but
what this tells us is that Jay Garrick
not dead he was just taken back to
wherever he was being held from which
means that Jay Garrick will probably
come back somewhere along the line it's
meriem same as DC saying hey guys look
just because Jay Garrick you know showed
up for a second and then vanished
doesn't mean he's gone forever we're not
yanking your chain he's probably going
to come back somewhere along the line
and what it does is it really kind of
creates this feeling of like yeah like
we're getting this great combination of
the things that we loved and the things
that we loved now and kind of be merged
and brought together into one thing but
the other half of this is that Barry
Allen begins to think back on the idea
of eobard thawne and this gets into the
second half of our discussion on why
eobard thawne cannot be killed remember
eobard thawne is part and parcel to
time-travel that's just part of who he
is
he comes from a 25th century in the 25th
century on the day that he gave himself
powers and the day that he made himself
look like Barry Allen and the day he
traveled back in time that's a fixed
construct that's never going to change
it's always going to be that way I mean
I guess Barry could go into the 21st
century and kill on but the whole idea
is the fact that Thawne is running
around means that he cannot be stopped
from ever becoming the reverse-flash
that's always going to happen it's an
immutable concrete aspect of the DC
timeline and because of that no matter
how many times Barry Allen kills eobard
thawne in the future or in the present
or in the past no matter who does
anything to them it's irrelevant
eobard thawne will always pop back up
again because he's always running back
and forth through time so it's almost
like there's an infinite number of
versions of them like there's a version
of Year Barth on for each particular
second
so you know you kill one this second the
one a second for now will pop back up
for whatever reason it doesn't matter
what it is but it's just this idea that
he will never leave he will always be
there and this is kind of cool because I
love the character of eobard thawne well
we'll find out how awesome he is as we
end up getting you know further in the
story but in the middle of his whole
birthday party everything is kind of
interrupted by a guy by the name of
Danton black now Danton black and this
story is by no means like a major
character I like he's a pretty
small-time guy I mean the whole idea of
this is that there's a chick named Sally
at this party she and dancing black like
had a drink and Danton is just like
we're in love like it was it was a weird
scenario so he literally shows up here
crashes this party just because he's
chasing after some girl now the other
half of this and something to keep in
mind here is that the parties also
visited by Hal Jordan and that's a cool
thing because Hal Jordan and and you
know really the flash were kind of
extremely strong friends in a lot of
ways one of the reason you know very
allen becoming like a blue lantern
different things like that there's a
very rich history between the two
characters both before the new 52 and
during the new 52 and so again focusing
on the idea of Danton black his
character really goes by the name
multiplex and he was a guy who gained
his powers at least before the new 52
years gained his powers in the same way
or really during the same explosions
that ended up merging Ronnie Raymond and
Martin Stein into the character of
firestorm and so the result is that he's
like neo multiple man Jamie madrix from
from our war comics in the sense that he
can make an infinite number of copies of
himself now the cool thing about this is
that unlike Jamie madrix multiplex is a
little more extreme and it's the extreme
nature of his character that makes him
so cool because facing off against Hal
Jordan and facing off against the flash
is a pretty difficult task for a lot of
people I mean one you're talking about a
guy who can move faster than time faster
than death faster than life in the
universe at the same time you're talking
about Hal Jordan the greatest of the
Green Lantern's depending on what fan
you're talking to you but a guy who is
Green Lantern ring could have can allow
him to achieve virtually any feat which
includes creating massive you know
constructs they can just round up all
these versions of multiplexes so the
idea is to form like this massive swarm
and that's what makes it so cool because
multiplex coming after flash and after
Hal Jordan it's like being attacked by a
swarm of bees each one containing
basically the orders of multiplex
himself and operating a candy lock into
what it is the
he wants to do and that's what's so cool
about this now of course the other half
is new 52 Wally West and iris West and
the reason why this is cool is because
while she's attending the party
alongside Wally quality basically in a
whisks her home and says hey look
there's this huge conflict you don't
really need to be here you're just an
average person you'll end up getting
yourself hurt but when they get back to
irises home they're met by the arrival
of eobard thawne and that's why this is
so cool is because this could happen due
to any number of factors it could very
well be that it's just some version of
gear bars on out there somewhere it
could be that it's eobard thawne who
basically healed himself we're not told
which one it is and eobard thawne makes
no reference to the events of the button
which is to say he makes no reference to
the fact that he was totally obliterated
and then returned so this is presumably
some other version of eobard thawne from
a different point in time that hasn't
been affected yet by the events of the
button because remember with eobard
thawne's whole idea of time travel it
gets absolutely bonkers and so I guess
we could say that what passes for the
past which is to say any version of
eobard thawne that has not ended up at
the moment where he gets destroyed by
dr. Manhattan could appear at any point
in time this simply seems to be one of
those when it comes to give our Thawne
it's it's hard to avoid the idea of time
but it's also easy to minimize the
discussion of tongues and so DC choose
time travel totally different from
Marvel Comics and it can make things
absolutely wild especially when it comes
to the idea of thoughts trying to keep
things simple here one other thing to
keep in mind is that gr Thawne remembers
everything before the events of
Flashpoint and that's what's so cool
about this is because this entire
discussion this entire conversation he
has with the new 52 Wally West is rooted
in the idea as if eobard thawne had just
walked into the new 52 from classic DC
and so he looks around and he's like I
fought a lot of different versions of
Barry Allen's protegees I caught impulse
I fought Wally West the other classic
Wally West Kid Flash you I don't know
who you are
and this is interesting because eobard
thawne puts the new 52 Wally Wentz to
task and demonstrating what he can do
now he's not doing it like a mentor
capacity right he's not he's not like
okay kid I'm gonna train you to be a
great flash because I'm a good guy let's
see what you can do it's literally just
eobard thawne testing him by trying to
beat the crap out of them and look at
what's happening I mean look
it's not a contest and that's what we
would expect like with the new 52 Wally
West his powers just not there yet he's
just now getting to the point where he
can begin harnessing his power in a way
that he can get relatively close to
controlling it but he's not very Alan
and eobard thawne is a chore even for
very it was just it's night and day it's
not a contest in any form of fashion not
only that the other thing you have to
remember about eobard thawne is that he
is fool and he is ruthless that he's
cunning for he's so charismatic but he
just pops you know that's the coolest
Freya the best way I can describe him
he's just so cool because of eobard
thawne it's not a matter of him setting
its sights on you and saying okay now
I'm going to kill you it doesn't work
that way
eobard thawne never just targets in
person he Abarth on targets you and
anyone you've ever met he goes after
your livelihood and the livelihood of
everyone you've ever known he just
erases you from existence and so if he
goes through the chronology of your life
and he's like okay so you were born to
your parents okay well I mean I guess we
can you know you're gonna be born so if
we're gonna go ahead and kill your
parents
ah you also had a really good third
grade teacher who helped to make you who
you are so we're gonna kill that person
you had a few girlfriends over the
course of your high school career so
we're gonna kill them oh you fell in
love and got married when you were at a
college so she's dead now uh and that's
literally what he does he's just like
we're just going to kill them all that's
what makes you have our Thawne so crazy
is because it's mind games a shadow game
it's every conceivable role every
conceivable task a person can take to
obliterate of a human being from
existence that's exactly what he will do
and so by the time eobard thawne gets
goes to work on it because the court
Ocean's eleven first he'll kill you and
then he'll go to work on you once she's
done it'll be like you never existed no
one will have ever known your name no
one will ever see your face you'll never
be there you'll it'll be like you were
just a person that was never there yeah
and that's the craziest thing is because
that's what he does that's where he
attempts to go after now the funny thing
about this is iris West because remember
this is new 52 iris West
for reasons that again we could only
really chalk up to the actions of dr.
Manhattan we don't really know what it
is iris West
does not remember anything before the
new 52 because remember what DC's been
toying with with the idea of DC rebirth
is that back in 2011 when the new 52
first launched that it was okay okay
here's a reboot here's new origin
stories these are all
new lives for all these characters DC
rebirth came back and said no that's not
what happened what happened is Barry
Allen went back in time initiated
flashpoint tried to fix it and then
after the events of Flashpoint
everybody remembered their lives all
these characters were still there but
then presumably dr. Manhattan stepped in
and said and now all your minds are
white now as far as all of you guys know
your new iris West doesn't know Barry
Allen not because of the new 52 reboot
but because of the fact the dr.
Manhattan modified her memory so she
would forget that was the whole idea
that's the whole basis behind DC rebirth
now why dr. Manhattan assuming it was
him why he did that we don't know we're
waiting for presumably Doomsday Clock to
tell us which man I'm excited about
deals like I'm like man I'm sorry I'm
super excited but these are the things
that are kind of being fleshed out but
from eobard thawne his mind wasn't wiped
he remembers everything he knows
everything that's been happening you
know now we're kind of left to believe
that in the time when he was defeated
you know after the events of Flashpoint
and the time that he really dr.
Manhattan acted and so presumably you
know it's almost like eobard thawne was
in a coma and then everything was
changing around him and he woke up after
it was changed remembering the way
everything used to be and so his really
know what dr. Manhattan did and if he
does he's not telling anybody and so
it's really kind of interesting here
because from his perspective iris West
the way she views herself and the way
she views the world that's not who she
is and so the goal of eobard thawne is
to grab iris West take her to the 25th
century and jog her memory to wake her
up and that's the cool thing here
because Barry Allen shows up to the
house right like once the whole battle
with multiflex is done once it's all
said and done once he has this
conversation with Hal Jordan Hal Jordan
says look man do not be afraid of what
will happen you not be afraid of the
idea that iris West will leave you if
you tell her who you are
be honest be open with her when he gets
back home to basically make that
declaration and say I Barry Allen and
the flash he ends up being met with
Wally West who's just been totally
decimated you know of course yeah Barth
on left a note inviting Barry to the
25th century but jummy back to the 25th
century proper the whole idea of gear
bar thon is to say I'm going to wake you
up I'm going to awaken you to the way
things really are I'm going to take
these memories that are suppressed or
whatever the case may be and I'm going
to show you who you really are and so
what seems to be happening or what seems
to seems like it will happen is it iris
West
remember everything before the new 52 to
remember everything in classic DC she'll
remember the first time she ever met
Barry Allen and fell in love more so
than that she'll also remember when she
married Barry and when eobard thawne
went back in time and killed her
what having said guys if we're gonna
bring this video to it in if you are new
here to comment explain make sure you
guys hit this sub button to become part
of the Rob for if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure your drop a like this
was amazing
but uh yeah I will catch you all later
please
[Music]